[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com it has been a long time since
I've been this disgusted with those
voters who insisted that there was no
difference between Donald Trump and
Hillary Clinton
I'm always disgusted with the Trump
voters that's that's a mainstay that's
nothing new but there were people people
on the Left ostensibly
who said in practical terms there's just
no difference between Trump and Hillary
a vote for Trump a vote for Hillary it's
all the same because whichever one of
them wins doesn't really make a
difference in our lives for our children
for our grandchildren they are both
representatives of maintaining the Toxic
status quo of corporatism and vulture
capitalism and so on and so forth there
was even a movement a movement called
Bernie or bust where lots of people felt
this way Trump and Hillary were both
tools of the corporate political status
quo and if it's not going to be Bernie
it doesn't matter some of them didn't
vote some of them voted third-party some
of them voted for Trump as a sort of
protest vote that idea and I'm not going
after the Bernie er Buster's
specifically here but the idea that
there is no practical consequence to
Hillary versus Trump has blown up in our
faces
yet again as Donald Trump is going to
get to select another Supreme Court
justice because Anthony Kennedy is going
to retire and is going to now by virtue
of this Trump will be able to influence
the future of the United States for at
least a generation including possibly
the repeal of roe v wade but Trump and
Hillary were going to be the same it
didn't matter
which of them won I told you earlier in
the week that the Supreme Court punted
on a couple of key decisions one
involving an anti-gay florist in
Washington State another involving
believe it was redistricting in
and I mentioned you know Anthony Kennedy
is going to turn 82 very soon courts
will sometimes the Supreme Court will
sometimes four go big precedent setting
decisions when there's a justice that's
close to retirement and exactly as
alluded to Anthony Kennedy has announced
he's going to step down from the court
at the end of July and everything that
any sensible progressive holds dear that
the court has influence on is on the
table at this point this is no longer
replacing a conservative justice with
another conservative justice this is
taking a moderate votes Anthony Kennedy
a justice who voted for same-sex
marriage who has voted for access to
abortions for affirmative action he is
out and he is going to be replaced with
a vile conservative ideologue the reason
we know that is because that's what
Donald Trump said Donald Trump said
before he was even elected what his
philosophy would be for appointing
justices to the Supreme Court and once
Trump selects one of those conservative
justices from whatever list he's working
off of at this point it will be one of
the most massively pro-corporate Supreme
Court's in history could be the end of
roe v-- wade could be the end to the
federal right to abortion and you will
see many states ban abortion altogether
Jeffrey Toobin has talked about this I
don't think we're gonna get to it today
but maybe tomorrow we can talk about
that and once this happens you're
talking about a return to the dark ages
and I think it is really important not
to be hyperbolic we are very careful Pat
to not make analogies to Nazism when
there is not really an analogy to be
made it's important to say to not say
this is the worst it's ever been if
that's not actually true we don't want
to be hyperbolic but what we are seeing
here is a decided move backwards away
from the tenets of modern Western
democracies and Donald Trump's selection
of an extreme lunatic religious right
ideal likely religious right ideologue
is going to be part of that yeah this is
really bad instead of having four
liberal justices and four conservative
justice with a mod
in the middle yeah now you're gonna have
a five-to-four conservative stronghold
the only thing worse I think is if you
know Ruth Bader Ginsburg or Stephen
Breyer or to retire or I'll go on to be
morbid but yeah I think that would be
the only thing that would you know
surpass this right what will surpass how
bad this is is when Trump gets a third
pick right that's basically what the
silver lining is there's more damage to
be done and the primary blame for this
is actual Trump supporters but behind
them are the people who didn't think
there was enough of a difference between
Trump and Hillary to justify getting out
to the polls in November of 2016 and
unless the Senate flips in November and
unless we get Trump out in 2020 unless
the next democratic administration
whenever it happens we don't know when
that'll be
puts together a serious and concerted
court packing plan the right has
co-opted of the Supreme Court
potentially for decades the untold
damage that Donald Trump is gonna do to
this country beyond his own life right
like now Donald Trump is setting in
stone damage to the United States of
America that will extend beyond his own
lifetime I hope that the Democrats in
the Senate are ready to put up a fight I
don't know if they are I wonder whether
Supreme Court justice Jeanine Pirro come
forth come I honestly I know it sounds
absolutely ridiculous I know Jeanine
Pirro wasn't on the Heritage Foundation
list of approved names for Trump but I
would not at this point put it past him
to consider not literally Jeanine Pirro
but something as ludicrous and
cartoonish he floated the idea of
putting Judge Napolitano on the Supreme
Court and he's another Fox News guy so
it's not outside of the realm of
possibility and if you're waiting for
Democrats to grow a backbone on this
I'll remind you that they may not and
even if they did they may not be able to
do anything because Neil Gorsuch is only
on the court because Republicans refused
to hold hearings for Merrick garland
during President Obama's last term in
office they said well we're only a year
from the presidential election we want
the voters to have a say before we make
hugely significant consequential
decisions about the Supreme Court and
Republicans won and Democrats I believe
need to play hardball there are just a
few months left until the midterm
elections why would we have confirmation
hearings for a Supreme Court justice
when in a few months
Democrats could take over the House and
Senate and completely change the caliber
and tone of American politics for the
two years that will follow
I implore Democrats to say and do
anything they can to prevent this from
going forward before the midterms
because if you replace Anthony Kennedy
with a hardcore conservative you know
what happens John Roberts becomes your
swing vote John Roberts is no moderate
and he becomes the swing vote when you
replace Anthony Kennedy with an
extraordinarily ideological right-wing
conservative what do Dems do hate to
warn you but most likely the next to
retire is going to be Ruth Bader
Ginsburg then you're talking about an
even bigger conservative majority and
elections matter whether you're a Bernie
or buster or a Trump and Hillary are the
same or my vote doesn't matter so I
don't vote whatever right you are a part
of the problem in addition to of course
the massive problem of 60 plus million
people voting for Donald Trump which is
the primary problem you're the root of
the problem if you're at rumpus you
didn't help if you thought Trump and
Hillary would have been the same and
I've been debating whether or not to
talk about this Pat we talked about it a
little bit in the studio yesterday I've
never been one of these people who says
I'll move to Canada um partially because
I know it's hard to move to Canada but
whatever the proverbial I'll move to
Canada the authoritarian slide the
attacks on press freedom what we are
going to see as out-and-out abortion
bans in many states after Trump makes
this change on the Supreme Court I've
started to think about what options I
have yeah and at least you have some
options right you go to Israel go to
Argentina maybe I've been Poland I don't
have any of those you're lucky in that
yeah if anybody can help Pat with a
place to go if anybody can offer Pat a
passport somewhere so that he would have
an option please write in and let me
know it's gonna get really really bad in
the United States activists have started
protesting Donald Trump staffers and
cabinet members I told you last week
about Department of Homeland Security
Secretary Kerstin Nielsen who
was heckled at a Mexican restaurant by
protesters later active it not later the
same day but later in the week earlier
this week more protesters showed up at
her house and had speakers playing audio
of migrant children crying at the border
as they were being separated from their
parents trump's completely loony advisor
Stephen Miller was heckled at a
different Mexican restaurant Sara
Huckabee Sanders was asked to leave a
restaurant in Virginia this is not
violence of any kind this is legal and
still there are people who have a
problem with it even Pat actually has
said that he sort of has a problem with
it as he said earlier this week there
are people saying we must be activists
but we must at all times remain
completely civil I want to give you a
little context about that idea Cooney
professor and historian Angus Johnston
found some articles from the New York
Times from 1934 okay and the articles
were by a Quaker named Henry Cadbury
and Henry Cadbury didn't like the
conflict that was taking place between
Jews and Nazis so he wrote an article
urging goodwill by Jews for the Nazis
and the argument that was being made at
the time was that the resistance of the
Nazis by Jews is just going to make
things even worse for everyone folks
know just know this is not going to work
Trump is about to appoint a Supreme
Court justice that could repeal roe v
wade and set off a chain reaction of up
to 20 states that will ban abortion
period this is not the time for signing
petitions posting flyers
and making phone calls this is the time
for action and I'm not saying violence
someone called in last week and said hey
David what do you think about an Tifa
burning down the child internment camps
as a form of protest and I said well no
first of all there would be kids inside
why would you burn down the place with
the kids if we're trying to protect the
kids but I'm not saying violence I am
saying the shaming and the taking up a
notch
of these public embarrassment campaigns
of these individuals when people and our
basic societal institutions are under
attack expressing outrage is the right
thing to do and making the people
responsible for carrying the policies
out uncomfortable is your duty never
mind
something that is acceptable don't do it
in a counterproductive way right if 20
years from now though the atour the the
authoritarian slide has become
institutionalized legal authoritarianism
and abortion is banned and same-sex
marriage is somehow repealed and
corporate power is given even more of a
foothold as a result of the Supreme
Court are you going to be satisfied that
you called up your representative and
you said hey message for Elizabeth
Warren's office please oppose Donald
Trump's nominee is that going to be
enough for you to feel like you did
everything you could I know that I
wouldn't Pat and I know that there are
many people in the audience who wouldn't
feel like they did enough either and the
problem is that in many societies
violence is allowed only top down those
in power can inflict violence on others
law enforcement at the border the
Supreme Court on women by banning
abortion or whatever other policy soon
as it goes the other way it's a big
problem I mean there's an example look
at what the forces of power did about
some football players silently kneeling
during the national anthem so we know
that top-down political violence is
acceptable as soon as you try to reverse
it things get real very very quickly so
the understanding that we have to have
is that there might be arrests and there
might be trouble and it's going to come
down to how willing are we to fight for
what we know is right remember when we
were saying that the Democrats should
shut down the Senate until Merrick
garland gets confirmed that didn't
happen and this is why it matters
because now Trump got Yael Gorsuch and
now Trump gets to replace Anthony
Kennedy and this is why the calls for
civility from those in power who have a
lot to lose if people realize how
outraged they should actually be are
hypocritical and they should be ignored
and there's a choice to make
okay we can say I'll live my life I'll
try to take a vacation when I can afford
it I'll go to the movies I'll play a
video game I'll read a book I'll learn
the ins and outs of vegan cooking
whatever right and wait for it to go
away before you know it what might have
gone away are not the problems but the
foundations of our society that you take
for granted while you sit there and read
your book if that book is even even
still allowed right because that's also
not a guarantee if you're with me let's
work together to figure out how to fight
this stuff we've got to do more than
just write letters to members of
Congress I applaud the people who are
coming up with new ideas who have been
reaching out to me and in the mat
background you've got to support
independent media right because there is
a three-pronged attack on independent
progressive media and if we don't
survive I don't know what we'll have
left because you're not gonna have
corporate media and you're barely gonna
have the internet with the net
neutrality repeal let's brainstorm
together what we can do I'm on Twitter
at depatment we'll take a quick break
and be back after this the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com big thank yous going out
today William Hooper not sure if you go
by Bill Bill Hooper William Hooper
William bill thank you thank you both
for being David Pakman show members
membership is the primary funding source
for our show we're talking about what is
effectively a constitutional crisis and
a crisis of separation of powers that
we're dealing with we've got to support
progressive independent media William is
doing it Teresa Bryden also as today's
new member a Hall of Fame new member
she's been with us almost six years six
years of membership for Teresa joined
bill and Teresa @ww June pakman.com 40%
coupon code is available it's vote soon
18 I don't care how much you contribute
whether it's a dollar on patreon or a $6
a month membership or a discounted
membership anything you can contribute
is money that says we understand the
crisis that our country is in and we're
willing to do more to try to push back
against it ww join pakman.com ok we've
got nearly 7,000 of our viewers and
listeners now regularly participating on
our subreddit a subreddit is like a
discussion forum except instead of
living on our website it's on Reddit you
can access it by going to david
pakman.com slash re d di t some
interesting discussions that started in
the last couple of days that i noticed
this morning that i want to point to
here is one I emphatically support
David's opinion regarding people shaming
Trump cabinet members non-violently in
public settings the only thing necessary
for evil to triumph is for good men to
do nothing voting them out takes time
protest is what we can do now are you
feeling Pat at all influenced by what
has happened in the last 48 hours to say
you know what maybe the public shame
campaigns are a good thing well to be
clear I'm all for protesting I'm all for
being aggressive I just
don't think that we should intimidate
people harass people you know deny them
service go to people's homes I think
there's a middle ground between these
two positions if would your mind be
changed if an elected official was
advocating for the death penalty without
trial of political opponents would it
then be okay to go to people's houses
and play sound of kids crying and bother
them at restaurants yeah I mean I like
the sounds of kids crying I think that's
an effective strategy to protest but I
guess I mean is would you feel
differently if you felt that the problem
was more serious if there could be a
place where the Trump administration is
doing something that goes too far right
and then it would maybe it's a matter of
drawing a line so in reality you
actually aren't opposed to the tactics
you just don't think it's gotten bad
enough to warrant the tactics at this
time I'll go with that for now Wow that
may be even scarier prepare for a flood
of hate mail for producer Patrick Ford
or maybe people agreeing with him maybe
people agree with that okay also from
the David Pakman show subreddit YouTube
introduces channel memberships
merchandise and premieres yeah we are
part of the YouTube sponsor beta and
what YouTube has determined is that they
are going to keep YouTube's sponsorship
but they're gonna rename it as a channel
membership so it's gonna be the exact
same thing if you currently are a
YouTube sponsor for $4.99 a month you
will just be grandfathered in to the
channel membership program I people
already started emailing me Pat saying
wait I became a youtube sponsor now
YouTube sponsorship is getting canceled
and I've got to sign up for this other
thing called the channel membership and
the answer is no no it is the same thing
it's just a name change that's all so
don't worry too much about it
also from the david pakman show
subreddit if you could travel back in
time to post World War 1 Germany and
your mission was to stop fascism from
rising how would you do it you know very
often people say I'd kill Hitler but I
have a different approach what about
just taking Hitler and putting him in a
particularly because the focus is on not
using violence as the thread starter
since bonus points for not using
violence put Hitler in a more nurturing
environment which would probably have
prevented him from doing what he
ultimately did get him into that
school he was rejected from that's exact
or sophistries that's exactly right and
sometimes we have this idea of history
as this we look back at history as if
this was the only and inevitable course
just by sheer math if you think about
three of the major sort of dictators of
the 20th century in Mao Hitler and
Mussolini there's a 50/50 chance of a
child being born a woman versus being
born a man roughly speaking it's not
exactly 50/50 but it's close enough that
means that the odds of Mao Hitler and
Mussolini all being born men is about
12.5% that means that there was an 80
7.5 percent chance that one of those
three was born a woman
dictators are almost exclusively men so
merely by something that was not that
likely it was only a twelve and a half
percent probability that you end up with
those three dictators history could have
much very easily gone a different way
and I think it's important to remember
that when we think about history as this
inevitable path it's the path that came
by chance and often even by very small
probability had two ways to look at that
I guess one is that we could have
avoided having to deal with those
dictators altogether by chance the other
is that who which dictators did we miss
out on because the channel being born
didn't happen yes and if you meet some
of the folks in my family you would say
had this person been born a man they
would have been a dictator we really
dodged a bullet because they weren't no
names no names okay last thought from
the David Brin show subreddit what is
David writing during phone calls yes so
we actually had a cancellation today for
our interview so you will see me doing
this later when we take calls I will be
making notes
I basically write the caller's name in
three-dimensional block letters that's
what I do on a piece of paper just it's
my I don't have time to do any artistic
stuff so as I listen to the callers I
write down their names in block letters
and shade them in 3d with very specific
light placement that's all I'm doing on
my piece of paper I thought you were
doodling over there but apparently not
no no I'm paying very very sure's maybe
of what you think the caller's look like
yeah that would be an idea and then
after the call I hold up a picture of
the caller that I've drawn that would be
something join the reddit at david
pakman.com slash re d di t hey this
might come as a surprise to you this
might sound shocking but North Korea
appears to be upgrading a nuclear
research facility according to new
satellite imagery now I want to remind
you that Donald Trump claimed victory
last month after his Singapore summit
with Kim jong-un he came out of it
saying we did it it is a major win I
trust the guy he has a great sense of
humor he's a great negotiator he's
extraordinarily smart and it seems that
the one true thing that Donald Trump
said about Kim jong-un is that he is a
great negotiator because he was able to
negotiate all sorts of commitments from
Donald Trump without actually doing
anything towards denuclearization and
we've now learned through new satellite
images that not only has North Korean
denuclearization not started they are
actually expanding their nuclear
research capabilities or at minimum not
dismantling them and North Korea
analysis done by outlet 30 by the media
outlet 38 North is reporting that over
the last month North Korea has been
making a number of significant
improvements to a nuclear research
facility new cooling water pump house
new buildings a new cooling water
reservoir a radiochemical lab that seems
to be active if you're preparing to
denuclearize you usually don't start
doing major upgrades to your nuclear
research facility now let me make a
counter point because there is a counter
point to be made here the counter point
would be the negotiation happened two
weeks ago and all we know is that this
progress in North Korea has taken place
in the last month meaning it's possible
that the upgrades took place four and
three weeks ago and then did stop after
Donald Trump's summit with North Korea
well it's possible but what's clear at
this point is that no denuclearization
has started which is exactly what Donald
Trump claimed this week was going on
Donald Trump saying they're way ahead
they are moving full speed ahead on
denuclearization
clearly they are not Jim mattis our
Secretary of Defense said that they are
not and now satellite images confirmed
that they are not denuclearizing who
could have predicted Pat that
denuclearization deals with rogue
nations could be a difficult thing to
manage completely unpredictable right
yeah I wonder what's gonna happen now or
the joint military exercises between the
u.s. and South Korea going to start up
again or the little rocket man tweets
gonna come back are we going to escalate
the situation and make it worse than it
ever was how dare North Korea for the
15th time not denuclearize after they
said they were going to denuclearize how
does that old phrase go fool me 15 times
shame on you fool me 1/16 time you can't
get fooled again is really the main
thing that we come away with I believe
that this entire North Korea thing is
actually a distraction from the Canadian
strategic maple-syrup
reserve I believe that that's really
where our national security focus should
be and this entire North Korea thing is
just a farce okay let's play devil's
advocate here Kim jong-un gets back he
has every intention of denuclearizing
but he's busy with his concubines and
public humiliation and assassination of
people and he just hasn't gotten around
to telling the nuclear research team
that they're denuclearizing but he still
has every intention to denuclearize is
that at all possible yeah I mean maybe
his priorities just aren't in the right
order I think who could have seen this
like that who could have seen this woman
we're completely blindsided by this it's
absolutely and utterly shocking Donald
Trump was the negotiator in chief wrote
the art of the deal I wouldn't expect
that from him yeah like I said I
wouldn't bring this guy to negotiate my
next car lease never mind
national international geopolitical
denuclearization send me your thoughts
if I'm being overly harsh on Trump here
and there there's some explanation as to
why everything's fine and we should
completely I can't even say it with a
straight face if we should completely
trust the promises of Kim jong-un
despite all evidence tell me tell me and
then I will come back to the audience
and say here is the best case that
someone in our audience was able to make
about why Kim jong-un can be trusted
join the subreddit at david pakman.com
slash re d vit twitch break back after
this the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the David
Pakman show we had a guest canceled on
us today right before the show and there
was just not enough time to get a new
guest so what we're going to do instead
it's rude when that happens we're gonna
take a few phone calls we're gonna go to
the phone's 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 see what
is going on with people in the audience
we will start with our caller from the
to15 area code caller from to15 go right
ahead
hello yes that's you hi I'm Jay I'm from
the Philadelphia area and I'm a big fan
thank you so with the recent
upset with the new progressive a lot of
people I feel like I'm really confused
by this and I just wanted your take what
do you mean think immediate they I think
they're confused by this Democratic
Socialist so the media is hurting the
left by using the verbage of democratic
socialists versus what we truly are as a
lot of progressives are social democrats
right if the person is a self-described
Democratic Socialist I don't know that
much about Alexandria Acacio Cortes but
if she's indeed are you saying she's not
actually a Democratic Socialist no I
think she is one but I think the right
is using the term so fear mongering and
it's I feel like it's gonna hurt a lot
of progressives that are gonna run the
Democratic side and do you think that's
gonna hurt us in the midterm election oh
my god yeah so listen I mean so the UPS
the upshot is the good thing is that the
term socialist is as popular among
voters as it has been arguably ever
maybe maybe in a very long time so on
the one hand the attempt to use
socialists as an ad hominem by the right
is going to work less well than it would
have been in Prior times but I do think
it's really important and this is a
tough thing because as you know DeRay a
lot of this stuff is nuanced and details
and you very astutely pointed out
democratic socialism and social
democracy they have almost the same two
words in them but they mean two totally
very different things like I am NOT a
Democratic Socialist but I am a
supporter of social democracy I think it
is important for us to understand the
terms so that we are at least using them
accurately because there are other
candidates not Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
who are being described as Democratic
socialists when they just straight up or
not and I think that it only allows the
right to take advantage of semantics and
fear-mongering when the left uses the
wrong terms that being said if someone's
a Democratic Socialist you've got to
identify them as such yes I completely
agree and I hope a lot of us do our
homework while we get out there and vote
thank you so much thank you really
appreciate the call great to hear from
you six one seven eight three zero
4750 let's go to our next caller we'll
try the six one seven number again I
don't know what happened before 6 1 7
are you with us hello hi go ahead ok um
so recently Charlie Baker's son was
there's allegations that he had groped
someone on an airplane and there's a lot
of secrecy around that like I learned
the investigation the police are like
refusing to release information about it
and I was wondering what do you think
about it and do you think it will affect
Charlie Baker I have this is the first
I've heard of it Pat have you heard
about this story but you saw the
headline do you so how old is Charlie
Baker's son do you know um I don't he
said he's definitely an adult but I
don't know how old probably around 30
yeah I have not heard about this I think
that his privileged position is the son
of the Massachusetts governor should not
impact the investigation the
investigation should happen
in the exact same way that it would
happen no matter who it was I do I have
reason to think it's not going to happen
that way not particularly but I would
want to make damn sure that this is a
fair investigation I don't think it will
impact Charlie Baker Charlie Baker you
know Republican governor of a relatively
blue state Massachusetts generally not
an unpopular guy and unless the
allegations escalated into something
worse I don't think it will affect
Charlie Baker all right all right thank
you all right thanks thanks for the call
yeah I just had not heard about that
story but I will I will look and look
into it six one seven eight three zero
47 50 let's try the eight one three area
code caller from eight one three go
ahead hello yeah I am Grayson I'm from
the Berkeley area and my question is
that given the Anthony Kennedy
retirement announcement yes how in
danger do you think that the Oberg verge
FLV Hodges decision is if I keep hearing
that it's not in danger it's a federal
decision right but I think that Gover we
optimistic I think it is so that that's
the case that said that unless I'm
confusing my cases which would not be
the first time but that's the case that
said that states can't ban same-sex
marriage we're on the same page right
that's correct yeah I think that roe v--
wade is more immediately in peril than
the courts June 2015 ruling on same-sex
marriage at the state level but I think
it is overly optimistic to say that
there is no way whatsoever to revisit or
to because remember it's all precedent
right that's the point so the court
wouldn't be able to go back to a June
2015 decision and say we overturn a
prior decision but the way that this
works when you get this type of judicial
activism going is that you start new
lawsuits around the issue at lower
courts and you continue appealing
appealing appealing until eventually you
can get something to the Supreme Court
that by virtue of ruling on they could
overturn precedent and that's kind of
like the
facto way it would happen I share your
concern Grayson I think that everything
is on the table once you replace Anthony
Kennedy with an ideologue all right
thank you very much appreciate the call
yeah Barry I mean this we're if you have
a feeling we're gonna be talking about
this for a very long time and tomorrow
on the show we're gonna talk about
Jeffrey Toobin saying he predicts 20
states banning abortion within a year
and a half yeah which is horrifying I'm
not looking forward to all of this maybe
a rough time in our history oh no this
this is more than just interesting
material for shows right this is
genuinely a disaster let's go to our
next caller from the four-to-three area
code 4 2 3 go ahead good afternoon
David impact any how are you I'm doing
fine I'm Dale from East Tennessee and
I'm very concerned about the way that
we're treating immigrants in our country
yeah and I wanted your opinion on but do
you think the normalization of
immigration camps as imminent and if you
see any parallels with camps that they
have in other countries such as
Australia so let's see I do let's talk
first about the normalization stuff we
are experiencing hyper normalization ok
if five years ago without the slide to
where we are today we had said from
today to the next day we are going to an
administration that's regularly
attacking individual media outlets
attacking individual private companies
whether it's Amazon or harley-davidson
or Jack Daniels or whoever else threats
to require licensing of journalists
which could be revoked unilateral
suggestions that we ignore due process
in the Constitution and start just
making decisions without people getting
trials or even attorneys if I said this
is where we're going tomorrow you would
have widespread outrage and people would
hopefully be out in the streets but it's
been a slow burn it started slowly with
fake news and the other little chipping
chipping chipping away and because it's
scandal o'clock every day
we've seen the normalization of horrible
horrible things and I would not some
people are saying to me David don't
we're never gonna normalize kids and
cages I don't know that I buy that Dale
I think that there is a chance that if
this just continues long enough and
three or four new scandals come up which
they will in the next couple of weeks
that even the pudding of children in
cages is going to become normalized and
I am as horrified as it sounds like you
are about it
ya know it terrifies me and I just worry
about the slipping of our rights every
day no question and what I'm sorry what
was part two of the question well you
know Australia they have some camps you
know it's become someone normalized over
there they don't talk about it
in politics very much and I was
wondering you know anything about that
and if you think that's where we're
going yeah I don't know anything
specifically about those camps but I'm
not at all surprised that it's become
normalized humans are incredibly
flexible as a species and
psychologically and we can get used to
almost anything as being the new normal
and I would be absolutely fearful of
that happening Dale thanks for the call
I really appreciate it thank you David
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's check
out the oh I don't know where do we want
to go next maybe the 732 area code it's
been a while since we went to seven
three two and seven three two can bring
really good things or it can sometimes
grind the show to a halt so we'll see
what 732 does for us today go ahead
seven three two hey how's it going David
good but you know this Supreme Court
you know Justice Kennedy stepping down
and the possibility of another you know
super conservative Neil Gorsuch type is
really stressing me out and I've been
pretty upset with Barack Obama of all
people about it because I feel like he
did not see any of this coming and he
didn't try to set his legacy in place
where it'll be beneficial to his actual
constituents and he didn't take Trump
seriously or take the Conservatives
seriously at all and I don't know who
you place the blame do you place the
blame with Obama I mean obviously
the conservative the Mitch McConnell did
all this but I feel like the Democratic
Party never took seriously just how
ghoulish the Republicans can be so let
me see I want to make sure I know what
your argument is you're saying that
President Obama President Obama for not
having taken Trump seriously enough
which led to his election and
subsequently him getting to choose a
replacement for Anthony Kennedy is that
is that what you're saying I think yeah
I would say it's Obama's fault for not
you know making it so precarious that
the only liberal justices left are in
their late 70s and mid eighties because
unfortunately they can also step down
and we could have up to a 72
conservative liberal Court and I just
don't think that there was the foresight
to say hey maybe maybe Ruth Bader bins
up sorry Ginsburg should step down
during you know 2011 we got a younger
liberal justice and it just seems that
there wasn't that kind of planning for
an event like what happened yeah man I
don't know I mean you you can what
you're talking about is Obama going to
Ruth Bader Ginsburg in 2011 and saying
that we might lose seats if the next
person is a Republican so I want you to
step down now so I can put in someone
younger that's not anywhere near the top
of the list of who deserves the blame
the blame mostly goes to people who
voted for Trump then it goes to people
who didn't vote who would have voted for
someone else but they didn't find it
apparently important enough to vote then
it goes to Republicans who successfully
obstructed Merrick garland when it was
the end of President Obama's
administration so there's tons of blame
to go around and Obama's he's on the
list but he's not high on the list the
way you're suggesting
all right we're losing you it seems like
your connections imploding I understand
and appreciate the question and and
hopefully I was able to give you at
least somewhat somewhat of an answer
there let's go to our caller from the
eight five six area code eight eight
five six we've got limit
time but I'd love to hear your question
I hate its Jensen calling again I wanted
to ask you in a parallel universe had
Hillary Clinton been elected what Alex
Ocasio Cortes have made headline because
I think that she got elected because of
the gag reflex because people are just
disgusted with Trump and ice wait a sec
would who have gotten elected the
progressive who just won in New York o
Alexandria Acacio Cortes yeah I mean at
this point you know we've got no way to
a/b test that right so there's a case to
be made that some of the progressive
wins that have taken place in the Trump
era took place because Trump won and did
everything that he did and if Hillary
Clinton had won then you would see
number one a lack of urgency to put in
real progressives and number two you
might even have Hillary Clinton as a
centrist Democrat helping other centrist
Democrats win I don't know the answer to
that I think that in all we can do is
anytime there's an opportunity to
replace a corporate Democrat with a
progressive when we do it assuming it's
a reasonably qualified person I know
people are already getting on me for
saying yesterday during a live stream
that although I agree with a lot of
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez's political
positions that I have concerns about the
depth with which she understands all of
those issues and you know I'm just I'm
just speaking my mind that doesn't mean
I think I would have voted for Crowley
if I had been in that race but I don't I
don't know that that thought experiment
is that useful beyond recognizing then
there is definitely activism that has
been inspired by the election of Donald
Trump the question now is what will the
activists do with that enthusiasm or
lack of in the November midterms okay
all right thank you okay all right
appreciate the call thank you glad we
were able to take some calls normally
don't take calls on the Thursday show
but we had a cancellation we will take
calls again next week talk to you that
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
a police officer in pennsylvania has
been charged with criminal homicide in
the shooting of seventeen-year-old black
teenager named antoine rose Junior On
June 19th criminal homicide if you
haven't heard that term before it can
include both manslaughter and murder in
Pennsylvania and prosecutors later will
say whether they're going forward
specifically with manslaughter or murder
charges the officer in question is
Michael Ross Feld and Ross Feld claims
that the victim had something in his
hands when he was shot could have been a
weapon multiple witnesses then came
forward and said there was absolutely
categorically nothing in Antoine Rose
juniors hands when he was shot by the
officer he was also shot in the back
three times in this incident that
started with a traffic stop of the car
that Rose was in Rose wasn't the driver
police said the reason for the stop was
that the car resembled one that was used
in a drive-by shooting that exact same
night during the traffic stop Rose gets
out of the car and is seen on video from
witnesses showing his hands initially
before fleeing no weapon was ultimately
found on him and he was shot three times
in the back by the police officer in
question this police officer had been an
officer in the area for many years but
had been sworn in to this particular
Police Department in East Pittsburgh
ninety minutes before the shooting and
had been on patrol for a few weeks
before the shooting he had been
previously dismissed from another
position because of what are being
called discrepancies between his sworn
testimony and what evidence revealed for
me the real issue is the shooting in the
back and it can be said well the having
a gun or not wasn't clear maybe the
witnesses all said there was nothing in
Rosa's hands but maybe the officer
genuinely thought that there was a gun
in Rosa's hands but even if the officer
believed that there was a gun because of
implicit racial bias for example in a
courtroom it is really tough to get a
conviction when you have at least the
possibility that the officer believed
that this individual had a gun in his
hands but then you get to the shooting
in the back three times you can only
shoot
one in the back if they're facing away
barring you know some really specific
wrestling on the ground type scenarios
that we have no reason to believe
happened in this particular case but
we've seen cases of suspects shot in the
back by police which still don't lead to
convictions and that's my prediction
here I'm curious to hear what you think
Pat I think there will be no conviction
of the officer criminally and then there
will be some kind of a civil suit
against either the officer or the police
department for responsibility for
Antoine Rose juniors death and the
reason I say this is not that I
personally defend the actions of the
police officer it's just based on what
we know probable cause the officer had
probable cause to stop this vehicle
because it matched the description of
one used in a drive-by shooting that day
number two if you pull the car over and
you believe that it's the car that was
involved in a drive-by shooting that
gives you reasoning for thinking that if
somebody in the car tries to flee that's
a public danger because if the car was
involved in the drive-by shooting or at
least I believe that it was and then one
of the people in the car flees it stands
to reason that they are armed whether or
not I actually see the weapon so this is
not my defense of the police officer
it's how it would likely be defended in
court I'm not saying it's right and I'm
not saying it's accurate I'm saying this
is a strong defense in front of a jury
and we know from experience that it's
really difficult to prove that an
officer didn't fear for their life yeah
and even outside of the specifics of
this case we've seen this before right
there's a pattern when we think it's
pretty clear that the police officer did
the wrong thing and maybe should be held
for you know some criminality some you
know even manslaughter murder perhaps
they typically just get away with it
and if there is any consequence it's
just a slap on the wrist maybe getting
fired from the police force in their
defense get away with it imply something
different then are often acquitted get
away let let's at least give the benefit
of the doubt that even though we would
like these situations to be different
that there is a
apparatus of sort of what constitutes
the possibility that you feared for your
life what sorts of circumstances justify
lethal force I'm not saying I agree with
them colloquially but I am saying if
we're going by what the justice system
would dictate not all of these are quote
getting away but it's the reality that
you need to meet a certain burden of
proof to secure a conviction in these
circumstances we'll see what happens and
I'm curious to hear from people in the
audience what they think about this
story Fox News and Donald Trump are very
tied together we know Trump loves Fox
and Friends Fox & Friends in fact is so
watched by Trump that Fox & Friends has
this kind of de facto agenda-setting
power as a result we also know that
Donald Trump and Sean Hannity have night
time phone calls where they chat and
then Hannity puts Trump to bed and then
Trump I guess goes to bed and tweets for
a little while before going to sleep we
also know that fox news plays
prominently in trump's propaganda
o´clock file twice a day Trump gets this
file from staffers with positive reports
about him and of course a lot of those
come from Fox News and now there is the
I guess we can call it the formalization
of a relationship between the Trump
administration and Fox News because
reports say that former Fox News
executive bill shine is going to be
hired as the at this point I don't know
if it's the 5th 6th or 7th White House
communications director spends on how
many times you decide to count Sean
Spicer because he held the position then
came back as the acting communications
the wreck I count that twice I mean I
think that it's probably the fifth or
sixth maybe even this I don't know
anyway the last person to have the seats
the the position was hope Hicks the
position has been open since March and
now bill shine is coming in bill shine
is a representative of the sexual
assault crisis that Fox News suffered
from he hasn't been directly accused of
sexual assault but he did resign in the
midst of CEO Roger Ailes and host Bill
O'Reilly being slammed with allegations
of sexual assault and we sort of have
the understanding that even if bill
shine wasn't personally involved in any
sexual assault he was probably looking
the other way about many staff reports
of sexual harassment and in a sense it
kind of perfect that bill shine becomes
the communications director for Trump
you've got a guy who also has more than
a dozen sexual assault allegations
against him in Donald Trump and then you
bring in Bill Cheyne who can look the
other way
about Trump's sexual impropriety after
looking the other way about the sexual
impropriety of Fox News employees so in
a sense it's like a perfectly fitting
match and it is the continued
formalization of what Fox has been doing
for a very long time now Fox sort of was
running communications for the White
House already Fox and Friends was a
mouthpiece for trunk which Trump
followed Sean Hannity was giving Donald
Trump advice and continues to give
Donald Trump advice on the phone just
make it official just get the guy in
there and have Fox News actually run
White House coms yeah this is the Fox
News the Trump administration pipeline
if you want to work for the Trump
administration you don't have to become
an expert in any field you don't have to
be a politician and work your way up
through the ranks now just work for Fox
News first they'll hire you it's a kind
of regulatory capture in Reverse right
regulatory capture normally means when
you have a regulatory agency that gets
taken over by people from the industry
that they're supposed to be regulating
so like if the oil executive takes over
secretary secretary the Department of
Energy now you've got oil executives
regulating oil companies as an example
this is an example of an administration
being taken over by the media outlets
that are supposed to be reporting on the
administration and keeping them
accountable and don't underestimate the
way that this could backfire for bill
shine he could end up like Anthony
scaramouche II on CNN within months
crying about how unfairly everything
happened or whatever it all seems great
right now for bill shine but it's very
easy to end up on Donald Trump's bad
side and things go very very poorly for
you
could happen to bill shine still yeah I
can't wait to see the Trump
administration staffed with Fox News
executives and hosts I know you talked
about Supreme Court Justice Jeanine
Pirro right maybe we will see vice
president Tucker Carlson press secretary
Sean Hannity yeah this goes on and on
bringing a new level of respect to the
office of the boat I would be Tucker
Carlson as vice president there
related to what we were talking about
earlier in the show it should be really
difficult for bill Cheyne to have dinner
at a public restaurant I'm not talking
about violence I'm not talking about
criminality but people expressing their
views in public is totally legal and if
you ask me what I really think about
this I think it should have been Sean
Hannity just a point Hannity and forget
about it because I think Hannity is
probably better than bill shine at this
don't you think um on I mean Hannity
makes way too much money over at Fox
he's not gonna take a position with a
lower salary
I don't think bill shine is getting a
pay increase to do this the salary for
these positions is usually think about a
hundred and fifty thousand and you know
bill shine was making way more than that
at Fox News right I mean am I wrong was
he not making more than I wanted he's
gone from Fox now right if he's making
zero now than it is more money that is
true we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p a
caller says that there is something more
boring than nascar that caller is the
Eggman and he says that it's the world
cop take a listen to this Oh Dave I
can't believe it you just said how
boring NASCAR is mind-numbingly boring I
totally agree it's absolutely boring the
worst thing to watch however the only
thing more boring than watching NASCAR
is watching world cup soccer people kick
it around the ball four to five two
hours to get one goal boring boring oh
my god how can you think NASCAR is
boring but think world cup soccer is
exciting oh my god David they're equally
horrible Orphic Stephen because it is
sports they should be considered bleep
eat that one brother I don't know that
I've ever disagreed more with the egg
man than here there is no similarity
between world cup soccer and NASCAR the
idea that World Cup soccer listen I
don't even know if I should bother
because if you don't get why World Cup
soccer is exciting and one of the best
sporting events that there is period on
our planet and you think it's equal to
NASCAR in any way there's nothing I can
say to convince you otherwise right
that's just it is beyond it's a cultural
thing it's beyond me the egg man is
going to space so much blowback
because while in the US here I mean we
pretend to care about soccer every four
years turbos Cup comes around in other
countries soccer is a religion and you
can expect the eggman to hear from some
people soccer is a religion and NASCAR
is a laughingstock in other countries
let NASCAR is a literal laughingstock
people see that and they say what is
wrong with people that they would watch
that and I agree with that view call me
anti-american if you want and people
already do right what's the big deal
we've got a great bonus show for you
today get access to the bonus show by
becoming a member or patron thanks for
watching thanks for listening will talk
to you then
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you